what's happening reject nation i was on
my way to the gym
and then olivia is on her phone and then
she tells me scarlett johansson's
in some business with disney at the
moment called up john and i said john
when i get back
all sweaty and smelly and gross we're
gonna talk about this
guys scarlett johansson is suing disney
because they haven't released the
spider-man no way home trailer yeah
she's ridiculous so upset she is the one
who's in this
patient not a laughing matter people we
need the trailer
and the plot leaks will continue from
scarlett johansen dammit
no she's suing disney over black widow
streaming
release now there's a whole article over
here i mean we caught one from cnbc
there's also like i think wall street
journal's the one who actually broke the
news but yeah she filed a lawsuit
thursday
in los angeles superior court against
disney los angeles superior court that's
where i did jury duty
hey you in a way have done jury duty
with scarlet i have
subcon so in six degrees separation i
have slept with scarlett john
absolutely alleging her contract was
breached when the media giant released
the film
on disney plus streaming service at the
same time as its theatrical
debut i'm going to take a side note here
to say like this is very interesting to
me because she seemed
really supportive of this movement and i
i
imagine what's been going on is they
were like well let's just wait to see
how this does
and if it then it starts to if it starts
to go down a little bit then okay let's
let's sue you know yeah it's kind of the
vibe that i'm saying proves to be a
disaster
than we will see because it had a great
first opening weekend but then it really
went down the second weekend a lot
anywho this article goes on to say mr
miss johansen said in the suit that her
agreement with disney's marvel
entertainment guaranteed
an exclusive theatrical release and her
salary was based in large part of the
box office performance of the film so
you know like when you get points
off of a movie that's usually what
directors but mainly like the stars of
movies agree to
which was kind of interesting to me
because i was remembering the wonder
woman 1984 situation
where patty jenkins and gal gadot i
believe
they were paid because they were putting
it also on hbo max and we're like look
this is kind of what we estimate
what you might have made if this was
just only theatrical release in the
theaters
so we're just gonna compensate you for
that and i
didn't see anything in here declaring
that that
she got compensated for also putting
this on the streaming service did you i
don't know
about that part of this conflict i think
is because you know they
said they were going to discuss you know
changing the terms of their arrangement
in terms of what she would have gleaned
from the box office had it just been a
theatrical release and then never
followed up on that
so apparently they weren't able to
renegotiate the terms
or offer up some kind of compensation
based on the early
projections pre-pandemic got it
according to the complaint miss
johansen's representatives sought to
renegotiate her contract after learning
of the dual release strategy for black
widow which she said
is her ninth and last marvel movie this
is definitely her last movie now
if there was any any hopes of her
returning i
i mean maybe disney has all the money in
the world they could be like
sorry about earlier here's double what
you got if they really wanted her back
but this seems like a nail in the coffin
the decision to put the movie on disney
plus is projected to cost miss johansen
more than 50 million dollars
a person familiar with the details of
her contract claim and this is the part
that stood out the most to me
disney intentionally induced marvel's
breach of the agreement
without justification in order to
prevent ms johansson from realizing the
full benefit of her bargain
with marvel the suit said let's do this
again disney intentionally induced
marvel's breach of the agreement without
justification
that's the part where i'm like what do
you mean without justification
there's a pandemic going it's still
ongoing and at the time of the decision
making where every studio was kind of
reactive towards the situation
the dual release strategy made sense and
it still does
kind of make sense for right now i mean
some
would really argue against us on that
however
i don't think to say without
justification is accurate
clearly this was done because of what's
going on in the world right now
i don't think it was in order to prevent
scarlett johansson an actress who
they've worked with countless times gave
her a solo film
like they suddenly have like a vendetta
against her and they were gonna make too
much money
yeah they want her to not benefit off of
this yeah yeah
uh i don't agree with that angle at all
i feel like
a lot of this was making sense to me if
she wasn't compensated
for putting it also on a dual release
but i put it also on disney plus
like that makes sense to me why you
would be suing like that seemed to be
kind of what the
uh worry was when the whole hbo max
release strategy
occurred and then you started hearing a
lot of all the directors being upset
yeah
about it like oh there's gonna be some
lawsuits coming their way right but i
don't think it's without justification
i think it's i think it was justified
whether you agree with it or not it was
justified
in order to prevent mrs johansen i don't
agree with that either uh i think it was
all pandemic related why would
disney would obviously have wanted this
to be fully theatrical release if they
could be
uh confident enough that they didn't
have the pandemic thing to worry about
absolutely if they said without
communicating it sounds like what the
true plot problem is they didn't
communicate and they didn't bother to
you know be above board in their
handling of the money in the wake of a
justifiable pivx exactly
this goes on and in march 2019 email
included in the suit marvel chief
counsel dave galluzzi
said the release would be according to a
traditional theatrical model
adding we understand that should the
plan change we would need to discuss
with you and come to an understanding as
the deal is based on a series of very
large box office bonuses so this email
is saying that should the plans change
we should come to a renegotiation
essentially yeah
totally reasonable totally of course why
didn't you do that
yeah but did they come to a
renegotiation that's what's kind of
unclear here yeah
and then uh john berlinsky johansen's
attorney said this will surely not be
the last
case where hollywood talent stands up to
disney and makes it clear that whatever
the company may pretend
it has a legal obligation to honor its
contracts now disney kind of has a
spotty record sometimes for working with
talent
i don't think there's any denying that
talk to anyone who's ever had a disney
show
of control yeah your circumstances yes
it's really horrible
yeah i mean there's more to unpack here
there's more to uncover honestly this
whole thing that the main quote take
away disney intentionally news marvel's
breach of the agreement without
justification or prevent miss johansson
all that
sounds like the kind of move and
strategy where you're trying to get the
court of public opinion involved
yeah like they were really conniving and
they want to hurt
all that yeah they want to damage her
ability to work and make money
yeah because i mean like from everything
i've been hearing here
there are parts of this that i uh like
depending on
what the whole there's so much to unpack
so i can't fully form a side yet
on which way to go what i will say
though
because she's also a producer on this
film if she indeed was not
compensated for um because at the end of
the day you're not going to make as much
box office when you put it on disney
plus
as well at the end of the day it's just
the reality of this i know plenty of
people who didn't go to the theaters
plenty like we did like i i ended up
buying it on
on the premiere access because we had to
do the reaction to it so
i ended up buying it myself and i know a
lot of people bought it instead of going
to the theaters
and if she isn't compensated for those
purchases then yeah i think she
has a right to sue now the the intent of
it is of
why of the the purpose is the only part
i'm more questionable about
yeah it just sounds like there was a
conversation that really should have
happened that they
said would happen that didn't happen and
that's a bad thing
yeah yeah but the question goes to you
guys what are you beautiful bastards
comment below let me know
leave your thoughts down below do you
agree with scarlett johansson are you
waiting to
uncover more do you think she uh do you
agree with the statement of
why disney uh breached their agreement
be curious to hear what you all gotta
say
no this is not something we're trying to
do like rage or whatever but it is a
fascinating story to uncover and and
honestly on a very personal note it's
kind of heartbreaking
just because scarlett johansson has been
part of the mcu since
the second iron man movie and she's also
i was really rooting for this movie and
granted i didn't love this film
however uh that doesn't really matter i
i always wanted her to have a solo movie
and she finally got the solo movie and
to see that only a couple weeks after
the movie's finally released after years
of being delayed
then now it's ending up in a lawsuit
there's a real bummer like that's just
the honest-to-god truth
that's not yeah you yeah
that part really bums me out um but
anyway leave your thoughts down below
and uh we'll talk to you guys soon
you